it's easy to write this off as this is  One Lunatic and of course it is a  lunatic but this is a tax-exempt church  and he's making open threats here on you  know which witchcraft give me a break  guys  you so much is tough wrong and I'll  expose you in front of body on this tent  you stinking witch  you were sent to this church to destroy  us you were sent to this church to lure  Us in you were sent to this church to  cast spell listen some of you been sick  cause you've befriended that witch  blaming but that's by the way this is a  this is a coveted crazy guy  um he called covet a fake pandemic in  December of 2020 he turned on Trump when  Trump started saying hey the vaccine's  pretty good completely turned on Trump  at that time so what he's even saying  there is those of you who think you got  covered you have to understand the the  what this guy's talking about those of  you who believe you got coveted that you  you were sick you had symptoms it wasn't  covet it was witchcraft